[Music]
not not with the devil and woody
harrelson like he's never been I watched
all the Austin Powers movies recently
quarantined alright guys well we might
get a venom T trailer we might not get a
venom two trailer while Sony keeps
pushing everything around seeing
particles going all over the internet
about this youtubers uploads in the
description about this apparently so I
was like you know what I remember for
infinity war I reacted to the trailer
description breakdown of that and then
the TRO that ended up being different
with some stuff that was the same I
thought it'd be fun to do that for venom
two elite trailer apparently so
according to everywhere online
specifically a reddit user translated
from Russia yeah they have a description
none of this footage is yet on the
internet but we're gonna read through
this and see what's in store for us I
haven't read it yet let's get down to
business
the trailer begins the logo of Marvel
and Sony the next frame is a view of San
Francisco while someone says a new hero
protects the city okay so think about
this sounds like a venomous than a zero
in this walk next we see a scene with
children dressed in the Halloween
costumes in a large house that makes
okay they were going for a October
release date which made sense for the
first one because venom going for the
horror looking at least on the trailers
they were going for that but then I
think that would correlate a little bit
better to release in October specially
for a trailer monster next a man opens
the door and gives candy to the children
you want some candy predator - this man
is Cletus Kasady wearing a mask
what kind of mask huh the mask then he
says John Deere Woody Harrelson
impression sweetness or muck generic
then he takes off his mask and it's
clear that half of Cassidy's face and
half of Karnas car nas's red face Oh
carnage yeah carnage really carnage is
renovators mouth of an HRT that he says
John Deer Woody Harrelson impression but
with a venom mix I think it'll be the
muck bad us next we see scenes with the
police chasing Cletus who is chasing
Brock in his red car
oh so carnage goes already it's good
that the red symbiote combined with this
guy who loves red stuff but - doing
going to children handing them candy
next a detective vests Brock or Cletus
is in the next scene Eddie sees the
newspaper about the burning of the
orphanage then Cletus voiceover says
taking the lives of others is pure art
this confirms the publication forged by
Tom Hardy Instagram a photo
hmm so so far what the trailer then is
revealing is that kids who he was
visiting must have been the orphanage
yes and he killed that that's a menacing
villain and the next scene we see Eddie
walking around the outskirts of San
Francisco and talking to venom he will
finish this next we see a scene where
Brock transforms into venom in the air
who was trying to climb into the church
where Cletus is located yeah Tommy get
him in a church then the framed are
tense and the voiceover of Cletus says
my goal is more than death
the final scene ends with the policeman
shooting at Cletus but he catches him
with a huge shoe pulse which I
definitely know the meaning might be the
word furs like symbiotic tentacle I
imagine you know dead you would need a
special then he is distorted and is
something else from what we saw the
policeman begins to scream okay Wow
there really sounds like they're writing
the you know the threat of carnage to
its maximum extent here at least in the
first teaser trailer like this if this
is the teaser at all because I remember
in the first venom teaser trailer you
don't see any of venom and the fact that
the venom movie ended with you know the
tease of carnage to come and then
immediately segwaying into this and
you're instantly setting up just how
sadistic of a human being how much of a
serial killer this this man truly is the
symbiote in the wrong human yeah can
lead to just some of the worst
destruction and like how this feels like
street-level especially with the fact
that they're saying at the very
beginning that there's a new hero in San
Francisco hinting at venom and then you
have or maybe could be talking about
Eddie Brock the journalist yeah yeah I
don't really break in those stories I
don't know what because this is better
to me than the first one words
oh man wants to do global destruction
evil internet guy this feels like it can
be a lot more person
I'm picking up from that post-credit
scene where you do have Eddie Brock
getting to personally know Cletus Kasady
sounds like it's just a great segue
through this tease it's like you know a
man killing children at the very
beginning is just automatically who that
sinister yeah and then also knowing what
Andy Serkis did with Mowgli it's not
gonna be afraid to really I mean the
last one didn't even come close to being
like an r-rated film but I think with
what you've seen that Mowgli film Andy's
iruka's knows how to push the line and I
think he will do what he can to get this
like a hard pg-13 hardest
yeah now now it's like yet the
description of the footage sounds cool
now I guess what the trailer has to give
missed a big inclination into is a look
it sounds like we'll be getting some
just obscure looks of carnage in here
which i think is the perfect way to
present him like when they're saying at
the beginning it's half of his face not
full form and then the police are seeing
him transform and maybe this will be at
night so some of the footage will be a
little bit difficult to make out but
they'll be good for an introduction of
VFX for a carnage I think that this
could be cool now is that we gotta get a
sense of the tone the atmosphere all
those other things that are essential
because it's all sounds cool on paper
now you know seeing how it plays out on
and a trailer will be different yeah it
really makes me curious because I love
the inkling I'm getting from this which
is that they might take it in a slightly
more monster-movie direction because you
know venom is a monsters character but
carnage is even more insane and depraved
than that and so I feel like especially
with the Halloween time setting and all
that stuff that there could be sort of I
know the first venom again had that sort
of timing but I feel like going down
that rabbit hole could be even more
effective here to intern especially with
you know other Marvel movies flirting
with and not necessarily going towards
horror if Andy Serkis could push that
line a little bit
this character this universe venom
antihero anyway seems like the perfect
place to do that this got me hoping for
a kind of a neat and change in the style
basically and some kind of increased
horror in
mm-hmm that's what I want and then yeah
there was like leaked footage to that I
think would fare like back up a lot of
what is being described here yeah I mean
obviously like the leaked footage was
like stuff those being captured in
camera on location so all the visual
effects would need to be added in which
I'm sure is what we'd see in the trailer
but yes so far everything that we've
been getting on this has been sounding
really solid sony has not pushed they
pushed a release date of everything
Morbius included so I keep imagining
that are going to push the release date
of this too because I'm sure that would
the way they're shaping up their Saudi
spider-verse
that they had a specific plan with
releasing Morbius first and then
releasing venom to next
so I find it kind of odd that there
would be like now let's just release
Morbius afterwards now in 2021 but let's
keep venom - I'm just not sure I don't
know what they might be reshaping they
might be redoing stuff in post editing I
don't know Morbius out the week yeah but
hey let's let's let's see what's in
store cuz yeah currently I'm excited
guys if you don't know this we just did
a video for with the cosmic Wonder
YouTube channel we talked about our
favorite the fan casting for and let you
guys vote on it and it was a wonderful
podcast that we did I think you guys
would really get a major kick out of it
there's leak in the description box for
it what do you think about this trailer
footage description does it get you more
excited for venom to leave your thoughts
down below subscribe to the reel rejects
click that notification bell we'll catch
you guys on the flippety-flip flip
flippity flip and also over to our
patreon page covering a [ __ ] ton shows
as well as a weekly Q&A podcast where we
take your questions
sever a lot of time do an actual podcast
out of it and music video reactions
weekly and other tears as well yep
you